Speaker 1: This is crazy to say, but courts
around the country courthouses are bracing
for violence as a result of Donald Trump now
being under three criminal investigations.
It almost sounds surreal what its courts are
bracing for violence because Trump is being.
How could the how could that be?
Well, yes, it is 2022.
And that's the reality that we live in.
I have an article from a Business Insider.
Trump is facing criminal investigations into
his conduct.
Courts are bracing for violence and chaos.
Donald Trump encouraged supporters to protest
where he and his company are under investigation.
Fulton County District Attorney Fanny Willis
and other officials aren't taking his comments
lightly.
Officials in New York, Atlanta and Washington,
D.C. are investigating whether Trump broke
the law.
The these cities are taking Trump at his word
and preparing for the worst in Atlanta, Fanny
Willis requested that the FBI assess the security
of Fulton County Courthouse and other government
buildings.
I'm asking that you immediately conduct a
risk assessment and you provide protective
resources.
One big reason for concern around Trump is
simply his presence in a courthouse.
A case or cases of this magnitude would likely
draw big crowds.
This would mean more work for law enforcement
and Secret Service.
We have the video, of course, of Trump at
his recent rally actually saying there should
be major protests, depending on what happens
with these investigations.
Speaker 2: If these radical, vicious, racist
prosecutors do anything wrong or illegal,
I hope we are going to have in this country
the biggest protest we have ever had in Washington,
D.C..
In New York, in Atlanta and elsewhere because
our country and our elections are corrupt.
Speaker 1: Now understand that the code of
what he's saying when he says if they do anything
illegal and corrupt to me in those places.
But what he's really saying is if they do
anything, I will tell you that it is illegal
and corrupt.
If there are any charges brought forward out
of New York, out of Atlanta, out of Washington,
D.C. at the federal level, what he's going
to say that it is corruption and that it is
illegal and he is already ginning up exactly
the type of violence that we saw on Jan. six,
though on the one hand, when we say courts
bracing for violence, what courts brace.
Yet it makes perfect sense of someone facing
criminal charges, and the court system has
to physically brace for violence.
Well, yeah, look at what happened on Jan.
six.
In fact, we almost need to fortify the court
buildings because we can't count on it all
being dealt with appropriately outside those
buildings because of what we saw on Jan. six.
I mean, hopefully it would be different, hopefully
in Atlanta or in New York.
It would be handled differently in knowing
what happened on Jan. six.
They would be prepared.
But it's a real and crazy thing that this
is being discussed.
The far right is sort of being worked up into
a lather of seething anger at someone for
all of the things and injustices that they
perceive to have been carried out against
them.
And there are certainly injustices that have
been carried out against the average person.
When we talk about the two justice systems
we have, when we talk about our economic system
allowing and even causing such inequality
and disenfranchisement, of course.
But their ire is being pointed at the wrong
place at election systems that are supposedly
fraudulent at investigative systems that are
supposedly targeting Trump with the so-called
witch hunts.
They are being told some things are going
to have to be done.
But it always ends up being a cynical use
of these people by Trump, either for their
money or, as we saw on January 6th, for there.
It's almost like for their freedom.
They traded their freedom for Trump when he
said, Let's go to the Capitol and more than
700 of them now facing criminal charges.
So this is a keg that could very well explode.
Now, I think it's important to mention one
additional thing.
I fear a rise in violence, regardless of what
happens to Trump and what I mean by that is
Trump in and of himself is not the root cause
of the weaponized xenophobia and disinformation
and authoritarian leaning.
He identified it as a good way to wrap up
this electorate that was to some degree made
up of people that we're not really even following
politics.
Up until Trump swooped in and said, Hey, here's
how you can get involved and help me rise
to power.
I worry that those people are likely plausibly
going to become violent over the next couple
of years, even without it being Trump directing
them to go to courthouses and cities where
he is potentially facing charges, which again,
I still don't think is the most likely outcome.
I think that there's a propensity here for
violence regardless.
And that's a really scary thing.
If you disagree with me, let me know you can
find me on Twitter at De Packman.
The David Pakman Show depends on the support
of our audience to fund what we do, including
most recently sending correspondents around
the country to interview people at different
events like we did in Conroe, Texas, at the
Trump rally a couple of weeks ago.
You can sign up at join Packman dot com.
One of the great membership benefits is the
bonus show.
And as I am now telling people, if Alex Jones
hates the bonus show this much, it must be
pretty interesting.
Oh, now I don't have my if I won't meant to
play my file, and now it's gone, OK?
Anyway, Alex Jones hates the bonus show, and
so that should at least make you sort of curious
about it.
You can sign up at Join Pacman NBC.com.
You can use the coupon code.
Wow.
22 to get a discount off of your membership.